We're following new tension
near the Russian border tonight.
Moscow now
says its fighter jets intercepted
two American military aircraft
over the Baltic Sea.
The interaction comes
amid reports of yet
another attack on Russian soil
near the Ukrainian border.
CNN's Nic Robertson is joining us
now from Kiev.
He's got details.
Nic, what is Russia
saying about this latest incident
as it also tries
to secure the border with Ukraine?
Russia
saying that one of its Su 27 fighter
aircraft intercepted
what it describes as two B-1B
strategic bombers
flying over the Baltic Sea.
It says it engaged with them
and according
or according to international rules, that
this was an intercept that's the way
Russia is describing it.
The Pentagon is saying
that there was
an interaction
of these aircraft
in that area,
that they were in international airspace,
that the interaction was safe
and professional. Nothing
to indicate at all that
it was anywhere near that
that that very dangerous interception
of Russian fighter
aircraft over the Black Sea with U.S.
aircraft about a month or so ago.
So the Pentagon
very clear
that this is something that happens
occasionally.
Why the Kremlin is making a big deal
out of it at the moment is unclear.
But certainly
the Kremlin is being embarrassed,
it appears, by
what's happened on the border
with Ukraine,
the country it's
at war
with calls it
a special military operation.
Some Russian fighters
appearing to be
have some level of support
from the government in Kiev,
although keep says that they're acting
independently, crossed
into Russia yesterday,
shot up a border area.
One civilian died,
according to Russian authorities.
Several others were injured.
But the backlash
from the Russian population in that area
was to call for that
their leaders to actually tighten up
and give them security
So Russia's
got this
very embarrassing
security concern on its doorstep,
right at its border.
Doesn't appear to have
adequate protection there.
And at the same time,
it does appear this evening,
at least
according to the governor
of the Belgorod region, that
a bomb was dropped,
a small bomb was dropped from
from a drone that landed on a road.
There were no casualties.
There was there was some damage.
But again,
Russia seemingly embarrassed
by cross-border activities
coming out of Ukraine.
So was
the information they provided
about the intercept
to draw people's attention
away from that.
Certainly, Russia continues
to want to pose for its population
that it's the United States
that's the threat to Russia,
not Russia, the threat to Ukraine
and Ukraine's civilian population Wolf.
Nic, Robertson
reporting for us from Kiev.
Thank you very much.
Meanwhile, in Russia
right now, the detained
American journalist
Evan Gross Kovic will remain in prison
until at least late August
after a court granted
Russian prosecutors more time
to try to build their case against him.
CNN's Kelli
Atwood is on the story for us.
Kylie,
what more can you tell us about
today's hearing and who attended?
Yes, that's right, Wolf.
The result of today's hearing
was that
his pretrial detention
period is going to be extended
by about three months
until at least the end of August.
Previously,
it had been till the end of May.
And so this was a request
that was made by domestic
intelligence officers in Russia,
who are the ones
essentially building
the case against him.
We know that he is facing
charges of espionage.
Of course,
those are charges
that he
The Wall Street Journal, his family
vehemently deny.
But it was really interesting
today, Wolf,
that journalists weren't
allowed into the courtroom.
But the folks that we did
see arrive
at that courtroom with his lawyer
or his parents
and Miscovich,
his parents
fled the Soviet Union in 1979, came here
to the United States, New York, City.
They raised their family in New Jersey.
So the fact that they made this bold step
to travel to Moscow
to hopefully see their son in court,
though we don't definitively know
many of the details
of what happened in that courtroom
because there weren't journalists,
is really, really interesting.
And here's what
the State Department
spokesperson Matt Miller said
when responding to a question over
if the U.S.
was involved at all
in their travel over to Moscow.
We did not help arrange their travel.
I can only imagine how difficult
it must be
to see your child detained
overseas, too,
especially to be detained wrongfully.
And so I'm certainly not
going to criticize any parent
for wanting to see their child.
But that being said,
we do have a level
four travel advisory for Russia.
And we also heard from the US embassy
in Moscow
saying that they were deeply concerned
by the court's decision today
to extend that pretrial detention period.
They also pointed out,
of course, that U.S.
officials have not been able to visit
Gersh Gavitt in jail for recent weeks.
That request has been denied
by Russian officials Wolf.
All right.
The update from Kylie Atwood,
thank you very much.
Let's discuss
this and more
with the former CIA
director of the former Defense Secretary,
Leon Panetta.
Mr.
Secretary, thanks so much for joining us.
Let me first get your reaction
to Russia extending
Evan Herskovitz, his detention
and this decision by his parents
to actually go there
and attend the court proceeding
earlier today.
What's your reaction to that?
Well,
it only confirms that
that Russia simply
has no judicial system
that that doesn't disregard
the rights of those that they've arrested
or it has now been extended
It's a deliberate effort,
I think, by Russia to, again,
send another message to the United States
that there in control of the situation
despite the fact
that his parents were there.
It only shows you how brutal regime,
Putin's regime is, how complicated Mr.
Secretary, are U.S.
efforts right now
to free Avengers go back
when Russia is baselessly
accusing him of spying
It's like
it's from Putin's playbook as a KGB agent
to basically use this kind of arrest
to try and embarrass the United States,
claiming that somehow
this Wall Street
Journal reporter is a spy,
which we know not to be true.
And so he's going to basically leverage
this kind of containment
by aggressive civic
in order to try to use him
as either
someone he can trade for somebody else
or he's going to use it as leverage
in dealing with the United States
on other matters.
So it's clearly Putin's playbook
that is working right now.
Let's turn
to the latest attacks inside Russia
while I have you, Mr. Secretary.
These were apparently carried out
by Russian citizens.
But is Ukraine
giving tacit approval here?
And is this a concern
potentially for Ukraine's allies?
Well, look, there's
no question
that the tensions
are increasing with Russia.
What they did in intercepting
those bombers
in the Baltic Sea is typical provocation
by Russia
when they're trying to send a message.
And the fact that that there were
anti-Putin, Russian militias
who conducted an attack
in Russia, in western Russia,
I'm sure upsets the Russians as well.
And they
they probably believe
that Kiev is behind it,
although Kiev has said
they had nothing to do with it.
So we're at it.
We're in a tense time right now.
When you when you look at everything
that's going
on, plus the fact that Ukraine
is attacking
other targets, largest article targets
to try to soften up
the Russians for a possible offensive
or all of that
is making things
very tense with the Russians.
At the present time.
The former defense secretary,
Leon Panetta,
thank you very much for joining us.